[موسيقى]
إنه ظلم المرض الذي
يصيب بشكل عشوائي
والذي يجد جوردون صعوبة في تحمله ،
فهو يصر على أنه لم يخدع أي شخص
في حياته في السبعين من عمره ،
ولن يتكلم أحد
عنه بالسوء.  عادة سيئة مثل
السجائر أو التبغ أو أي شيء أبلغ من العمر
70 عامًا.
لم أواجه أي خلاف مطلقًا مع أي شخص ، فلماذا
يحدث هذا لي
وهو يناشد الصيدلي المحلي
، لقد بذل الكثير من الجهد للمساعدة ولكن
توفي العشرات هنا في الشهر الماضي وهم
مريضون منذ ثلاثة أسابيع ،
هذا هو منزل جيتسو ، ومعظم المزارعين في هذه
القرية الغوجاراتية في غرب الهند هم
مزارعون
يتمتعون بتربة خصبة ووفرة من
الماشية
عندما اجتاحت موجة الوباء الثاني
في الهند المدن الجماعية في الهند الناس
في المناطق الريفية
لم يسلم
من عدم وجود طبيب القرية أو المسعفين
ونقص أسرة المستشفيات في المدن البعيدة
يعتمد الكثيرون هنا على خبرة g2 بصفته
صيدلانيًا حصل على الأوكسجين والأدوية الموصوفة
ولا يوجد أحد هنا ولا صحة  مركز لا
طبيب لا ممرضة
لا توجد مرافق في هذه القرية ،
لذلك تعاملت مع الأمر بالطريقة التي رأيتها
مناسبة تجعلك
غاضبًا ، لكن ما الذي يمكن للمرء فعله
ليس لدينا حلول
يقول دينيش إنه حاول ذلك  نقل والده
جيفراج إلى أربعة مستشفيات لكنها كانت
ممتلئة ،
تم تشخيص والده بأنه مريض مرغوب بشدة
، شهد راج الدمار الذي لحق
بقريته ، لكن خوفه لم يعد الموت ،
بل أن السر سيدمر عائلته التي
أصيبت ابنته وزوجته أيضًا
إنها تكافح من أجل التنفس في الشرفة الأرضية الخاصة بهم
تحت أعين الآلهة الهندوسية ،
منزلهم ليس بعيدًا عن
محرقة الجثث بالقرية حيث
تحولت جهود المتطوعين من
جيتو إلى جياغاشينغا حتى اليوم يقوم بحرق جثث
الناس
بشكل مستمر تقريبًا الآن الآن يزيل رفاتهم
وقد أحضر المزيد من الخشب  لما
يخشى أن يأتي
في القرية ، هناك
منازل فقدت ما يصل إلى ثلاثة أشخاص ،
ابن عمه ، أمه ، فقد احتفظ بسجلات دقيقة ،
لذا فقد احتفظ بسجلات دقيقة في الشهر الماضي فقط.  يقول لي
أن هذه هي القائمة التي أحرق فيها
90 شخصًا في المتوسط
ي أحرقه 30 شخصًا على مدار 12 شهرًا ، 90 في
عاء واحد جاهز للعائلات لن
ل رماد ال
رار الميتة التي صنعها جوفاردان الخزاف قبل أن
م
ض  مرض أصاب الكثير من جيرانه
سام كيلي سي إن إن